Hey Wolfgang!
Hallo Stefan, wir wollen verkünden, was wir als nächstes lesen.
Wir haben ja im aktuellen Salon ausführlich über Rutger Bregmanns Buch im Grunde
gut diskutiert, waren uns damit unter uneins, sind aber dann auch,
glaube ich, in vielen Dingen uns wieder einig geworden.
Wir waren mit uns uneins und mit dem Autor.
Und mit dem Autor, ja. Und die Idee war ja von Prickmann so eine neue Geschichte
der Menschheit zu schreiben mit der These,
eigentlich ist der Mensch gut, aber es gibt da gewisse Faktoren,
die dann dafür sorgen, dass er sich nicht gut verhält, zum Beispiel schamlose Politiker.
Ja, die kommen wir auf jeden Fall so sehr zurück.
Wir müssen die Triggerpunkte, zentralen Sachen häufiger betonen und dieses von
uns ja, wie wir sagen, von dem Autor leider nicht so krass, wie wir uns das
wünschen, ausgearbeitete These, dass mit den Politikern irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Du hast ja eben die Meldung schon gelesen wahrscheinlich. Olaf Scholz sagt,
ja, wir werden weiter aufrüsten und wenn das Sondervermögen nicht reicht,
wir werden nicht von der Schuldenbremse gehen, wir werden kein neues Sondervermögen
schaffen, sondern dann müssen wir bei den Sozialabgaben sparen.
Ja, habe ich noch nicht gesehen, aber ich habe heute schon drei Stunden Podcast
im Ohr von der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, wo sie alle sagen,
also Scholz, das war ja nochmal unter Scholz-Niveau.
Wahrscheinlich hat er jetzt einfach nochmal nachgeliefert.
Prima, ja, so viel zum Thema Schamlosigkeit, da kann man ja nur hoffen,
dass die künstliche Intelligenz uns weiterhilft und ja, das ist jetzt unser
neues Buch, dass wir wieder eine Geschichte der Menschheit bekommen,
aber eine von der Zukunft und die Frage ist, welche Rolle spielt dann in der
Zukunft der Mensch noch?
Und zwar lesen wir von Mustafa Suleiman, The Coming Wave, Künstliche Intelligenz,
Macht und das größte Dilemma des 21.
Jahrhunderts, erschienen bei CH Beck.
Dieses Buch wird empfohlen von Daniel Kahnemann, von Bill Gates,
von Yuval Noah Harari, also große Namen sind darunter.
Und wer Mustafa Suleiman nicht kennt, kennt wahrscheinlich sein Unternehmen,
das er mit gegründet hat, nämlich DeepMind.
Er ist Jahrgang 1984 Sohn eines syrischen Taxifahrers und einer englischen Krankenschwester,
der dann eine extreme Karriere gemacht hat weltweit, der AI-Experte ist.
Und der hier skizziert, welche Herausforderungen eigentlich die AI für uns so bedeutet,
wenn wir zum einen dadurch eine große Befreiung erleben, wir aber zum anderen
nicht sicher sein können, wie weit wir dann noch die Kontrolle darüber haben. Ja.
DeepMind, für alle, die das nicht wissen, ist eine Londoner Firma,
die damals Google gekauft hat, weil die schon erste Anzeichen von künstlicher
Intelligenz und so weiter.
Und daraufhin haben die DeepMinder zu Google gesagt, ihr könnt uns kaufen,
aber in unserem Exit-Vertrag muss drinstehen, dass ihr ein Ethikrat gründet.
Und ich habe dann damals bei dem Google-Büro in Berlin nachgefragt für die FAZ,
was hat es denn mit diesem Ethikrat auf sich?
Was weiß denn DeepMind über künstliche Intelligenz und über Google,
dass sie sagen, da braucht man jetzt auch noch ein Ethikrat?
Und es kam nie eine Antwort. Das Berliner Google-Büro wusste über nichts Bescheid.
Wir ergänzen das mit einem zweiten Buch, das ich aber nur kurz durchswitche,
um sozusagen da Anschluss zu finden direkt.
Alexander Karp, das ist ja der Chef von Palantir, hat vor einem Jahr ein Buch
über von Artificial zu Augmented Intelligence, was wir von der Kunst lernen
können und so weiter für die Künstliche Intelligenz.
Also das, wir werden also hier,
es ist ganz interessant, dass wir Autoren haben, die es selber machen.
Das sind keine kommentierenden Autoren, sondern das sind die Macher selbst.
Ja, das finde ich auch ganz hervorragend. Also Mustafa Suleiman hat sich noch
einen Journalisten dazu genommen, um dieses Buch zu schreiben,
was in der Regel den Lesefluss erleichtert, so hoffen wir zumindest.
Und ich glaube, es ist ein Buch, über das wir dann viel diskutieren können,
da ja wir auch immer darüber spekulieren oder uns auch da uneins sind,
inwieweit AI jetzt wirklich das ganz große Ding ist.
Und er spricht tatsächlich davon, dass wir also verschiedene Wellen erleben,
da ist dann die landwirtschaftliche Revolution,
da ist die Dampfmaschine, da kommt das Internet und jetzt kommt die künstliche
Intelligenz und die Frage ist, wie gehen wir also mit dieser neuen Welle um und er sagt.
Beginnt auch damit, dass er erst einmal AI natürlich fragt, eine KI fragt,
wie sieht das dann in Zukunft aus mit der Menschheit, die antwortet und dann
steht extra im Buch die Anmerkung,
obiger Text wurde von einer KI geschrieben und von einer KI übersetzt.
Für den Rest dieses Buches gilt das nicht, obwohl es bald so sein könnte.
Das nämlich kommt auf uns zu.
Ja, und dann beginnt er, tatsächlich sind wir da wieder in diesem Diskurs,
wie erzählen wir die Geschichte der Menschheit.
Er beginnt damit, dass er sagt, so gut wie jede Kultur kennt einen Flutmythos
und dann skizziert er das kurz,
also wie Kulturen Flutmythen erschaffen haben, wie sie mit einer Flut auch umgehen
und diese Metapher verwendet er dann, um zur künstlichen Intelligenz zu kommen.
Also wir können, glaube ich, sehr gespannt sein und wer also das Buch schon
mitlesen will, schon vorher lesen will, bevor wir den Salon dann Anfang März
veröffentlichen, kann das jetzt tun.
Nun, wir wollen auch noch darauf hinweisen, dass wir im aktuellen Salon schon
bekannt gegeben haben, wann unser Sommer-Event stattfindet und wie man an Karten kommt.
Der Kartenvorverkauf läuft auch bereits. Ich glaube, es sind schon so etwa 250
Karten verkauft, aber es ist noch jede Menge Platz.
Also wer sich dafür interessiert, kann das im aktuellen Salon hören.
Und jetzt, Stefan, zu guter Letzt, verrate uns noch, wie man in den Salon kommt.
Man geht auf neue20er.de, unsere Einflugschneise.
In die menschliche Intelligenz und dort klickt man auf den gelben Button,
der den Salon-Schriftzug trägt.
Dann ist man auf der Seite von Steady. Wir bevorzugen Steady und können es da
am günstigsten machen für alle.
Da kann man für 2,50 Euro im Monat den Salon buchen. Man kriegt ein,
wenn man eh schon Podcast hört, was wir ja glauben, für die Leute,
die wir hier erreichen, eigenen RSS-Feed, hoch individuell.
Ich glaube, wir könnten sogar noch den Namen des Kunden, quasi des Hörers, mit reinschreiben.
Bei Twit machen sie es so, habe ich gesehen.
Und dann kriegt man alles, was ein Podcast bietet.
Uns, Kapitelmagen, einen kleinen Text, wir kriegen die Literatur aufgelistet,
die wir lesen, verlinkt.
Es gibt, wir könnten eigentlich auch mal im Salon ein Transkript mit anbieten und der ganze Kram.
Also man findet einen vollständigen Podcast, den man man in seiner Lieblings-Podcast-App einfach hören kann.
Ansonsten, neben Steady, Patreon, für die, die den schon Account haben,
die wissen dann auch schon, wie das funktioniert.
Oder wer ein iPhone hat, um Podcasts zu hören, klickt einfach für ein Euro mehr
pro Ausgabe auf die und dann im Feed eingebettete, nicht in einem extra,
in einer extra Nische angelegten Salon.
Prima. Und dann hören wir uns Ende des Monats mit der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
und vielen anderen Themen.
Yes, bis denn.